hi I'm Evan Carmichael and welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in this
video I'm going to answer a question for
one of our readers soul blab blasts how
do you overcome them for your projection
while selling so I'm going to share with
you a couple strategies that i use and
hopefully you can learn from that and
put its use in your business as well the
first is you have to know that the
product or service that you have is
actually going to be helpful and useful
for the person you're talking to and
that may seem like common sense but a
lot of times you know you may not
actually believe in your product or
service that much and it's then harder
to be convincing and make a good sales
case when you're talking to your your
prospect for me most of the sales I do
are pretty standard you know I'm in the
groove and it's pretty comfortable but
every now and then as I'm growing my
business I'll get more and more
corporate interest and bigger deals that
are coming to me and every time I'm on
the phone with a client that could be
you know my new biggest deal yet a
little bit of nervousness and load of
excitement and I'll always calm down by
reminding myself that what I'm offering
them is really really going to help them
and that's what I focus on so I'm not
focused on you know trying to be nervous
or trying to really sell them I'm just
trying to help them out as much as I can
the second thing is try to be a resource
and sometimes you don't get the sale and
you give customers away so one of the
things that i'll sell is a mastermind
group and that's a group where we'll
connect entrepreneurs together every
month and we talk about our businesses
and try to help each other out and
that's a paid membership that i'll make
some money from and what I'm talking
about that group it's never a hard sale
it's more trying to find out about the
challenges of my you know prospect is
going through and seeing if it's going
to be a good fit for me or not and a
good fit for them as well and most of
the time it is but sometimes it may not
be what they're looking for and in that
case I'll pass them on to somebody else
that might be a better fit so this
example sometimes I've passed people
onto a business coach where they may be
needed a little bit more intense system
to work with so working with
cisco she makes sense instead of joining
a peer groups that we have the classmen
group so if you're open and honest and
you know that you're you know trying to
help them out as much as possible I find
that really eases the fear of going into
that initial meeting the last strategy
that I use is something called negative
reverse selling and that's when if you
think about when somebody tries to sell
you understand you got apply this by
this by this you're likely reaction is
going to be on up buying that you're
going to back boy so the approach it you
want to take is the opposite and if
sometimes we go negative on it people
have even see the one to take the
opposite view and go positive so a
couple quick examples I'm doing a
presentation so if we're talking about
the masses my groups for example I might
say oddly don't talk about all the
different benefits of it and then at the
end say something like it does that make
sense to you or is this coming out of
left field and usually they'll say
something like oh no make sense great
that's dope it's exactly what I wanted
and so if I going a little bit negative
it makes them go positive or if I said
at the end you're just the best thing
ever you really need to buy it they're
probably going to take the more
defensive stance so people like wine the
opposite of what you're doing another
example so I'm selling to a bigger
corporate client I might say something
like you know we've been able to help
out a lot of different corporations but
it only really works we can only help if
you're targeting the entrepreneur
community if you're not targeting
entrepreneurs and you know I don't think
we're going to be able to help you
that's the truth you know somebody's
trying to target managers at banks or a
different target audience I'm not going
to really be able to help them target
entrepreneurs I can and by saying
sequence like that they always come
backs no no we're targeting
entrepreneurs this is our market exactly
we're looking forward to learning a
little bit more about what you do and so
gets emceeing yes and gets them involved
and by me going negative it also reduces
the fear of them say no so I hope that
helped some of those strategies might be
useful for you if you guys liked the
video please give it a thumbs up but
also love to hear your thoughts and
feedback if you want to leave a comment
below the video and stay tuned for the
next episode
you